all right ryan gosling makes his
triumphant return as his new action
flick the gray man streams on netflix
this weekend very good to know and our
very own keisha shante got the chance to
catch up with the young canadian legend
and i'm so jealous
and while he might be playing a super
spy in the film talk quickly turned to
superheroes with ryan spilling which
marvel character he'd love to play
what superhero would you like to play if
you could play anyone
i mean the one i always thought was the
coolest was ghost rider okay but i
always felt like that was taken
you know
um you know
but i wonder what i just don't know what
the waiting period is on that
you know
obviously you know ava's giving it her
blessing she's she's
she's cool but you know there's a lot of
i need the blessing from a lot of other
people yeah i need kevin's
nick cage the marvel fans that's there's
a there's a checklist that has to happen
and i don't if you want to if you can
the petition put in a word or something
i will call it like a and not exhausting
that hasn't done so much
yeah man
dude uh so in case you're feeling like
this came out of nowhere marvel has been
getting in touch with their dark side in
phase four we had harrington's dane
whitman also known as black knight and
eternals having a meat cute with the
ebony blade and of course marshall ali's
rebooted blade can't wait most recently
oscar isaac as moon knight and the
upcoming werewolf by night with gael
garcia bernal oh my gosh i am here for
all of that and thanks to all of that
fans have been speculating that the
midnight suns could be upon us with
rumors that john bernthal would be
reprising his role as punisher i know
you're a huge fan
and lots of fans are calling for mr
norman reedus to tackle the role of
ghost rider previously played by nick
cage in the 2007 film the question is
carlos would ryan make a good ghost
writer what are your initial thoughts
yes
okay why of course why he's a great
actor he is a good actor he can he as
far as i'm concerned like he could play
pretty much
anybody right i think ghost rider is a
great fit for him drive fantastic movie
one of his most well-known uh wonderful
films hits i should say um you just
think about the character in that and
apply you know the spirit of vengeance
and a motorcycle instead of a cool car
and and you're you know you're there
you're halfway there at least and just
to confirm the ghost rider goes after
the spears that have escaped hell
the bad guys like the bad guys right
like he's got ghost riders got cool
powers got a great story and listen to
the nick cage movie as fun as it was and
it did well it actually did really well
at the box office but the critics didn't
love it
um you know it was in sort of this
period of time for superhero movies
before we hit the renaissance after iron
man it's true uh that it was kind of
like
it almost felt like you couldn't really
tell the story the way it
it
should be told because you had to make a
movie first if that makes sense and then
they made that sequel spirit of
vengeance which is just so bonkers crazy
i actually enjoy it quite a bit because
it's so weird it's so out there i don't
know it's way better
it's way more nic cage even than that
than the first ghost rider movie um
but
norman reedus
right like here's the thing like norman
readers as people were immediately like
yes
of course so i didn't really realize
this but norman reedus actually posted
fan art that someone made with him as
ghost rider and he posted that like a
month or two ago in his on his story so
i think that's also fueling rumors
whether he's on board for it whether
that's his like claim to be like oh just
throwing that out there yeah marvel uh
but i think a lot of people want to see
that happen i am really curious for the
people that have been on board for for
norman rene's casting as ghost
ghostwriter and i've been on board for
that too what their reaction is to
hearing ryan gosling say that that's
what he wants
because like i could see them
each of them right like each of them
would be really great but the thing
about ghost rider that's
wonderful i guess for both these guys is
that it's not just one person that
becomes ghost rider yeah so there are
they could each play different
characters that become ghost writers
like there's it could happen and you can
tell he's had these conversations with
his his lady who was in the first she
was like i actually kind of forgot so
the fact that he brought that up you
know they have had some wine yeah or
morning coffees and they've talked about
this and he's probably like yo when can
we redo this because maybe he has a good
idea of how he would approach this
here's what i'm not sure i want more now
okay do i want norman reedus and ryan
gosling both as like the different ghost
riders in this one movie together wait
wait that can happen there's two
different versions there are two like
they could each play
the different guys that become ghost
riders oh i understand i have two of
those guys
okay or or do i want nicholas cage as
the original ghost writer
having a cameo in a new movie starring
either norman or ryan because nick cage
adding a little a little bit of nic cage
on something
always makes
yeah yeah right he's having a major
comeback right now nick cage everyone
was like bring him back so i think this
would actually be the perfect time to
bring him back because i think the
hardcore fans will be back to see that
the nic cage die hard fans in general
not even ghost rider and then of course
either norman reedus or ryan gosling
down i never forget there's the
multiverse right there's all sorts of
ways to do this okay
let's see what people are saying solo
studios is saying ghost ride aka johnny
blaze would be perfect for ryan i'm
totally down for that
and
i am seeing
[Applause]
that that's it guys there's a lot of
comments today i really appreciate it
but just to focus on ghostwriter that's
the only one i got yeah and and before
we go that whole dark mcu phase four
thing that they're kind of leaning into
right i want it to happen this is where
it needs to go i agree like this is like
go in head first full steam ahead go
slider get the punisher back yes agree
agree